we couldn't see real technologies coming
into the to the food industry it was
very
conservative i would say and as an
entrepreneur i was
i was amazed i just thought about it
that what we can do
in addition to what we have today into
the food industry how much innovation
we can bring to that to that segment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
food is changing all around us and today
we're going to meet one of the bigger
influencers in the space
meet rachel wiesmann co-founder and ceo
of savor eat
rachel wiesmann has years of experience
in the entrepreneurial arena and in
leading companies for ipos in the
technology and healthcare industry
before founding savory she served as ceo
at beyond air
a clinical stage medical device and
biopharmaceutical american israeli
company
saver each went public on the tel aviv
stock exchange in the first ipo of a
food tech company in tel aviv rachel
visman
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders welcome from
savory how are you i'm doing great thank
you
very happy to be here today thank you
for spending these 20 minutes with me
um there's a personal story here behind
slavery that i'm excited to hear about
but i'm also looking forward to learning
a little bit more about what it takes to
bring
you know healthcare and and these types
of companies to ipo both in the
television stock exchange are also
a part of of beyond air from inception
really until it went public in the us
and i'm
looking forward to to hearing that story
as well and and more generally
what you've learned in the domain that
you're in so so rachel
you know before we even talk about you
know savory or beyond there
who is rachel if you look at your career
and who you are
how would you characterize yourself
um i think that i i born and raised as
an entrepreneur
uh all the time looking for uh um to
identify problems and to try to find
solutions for them
i think that's what drives me um taking
um
identifying problems and trying to
think about you know in a creative way
how to solve it um
i would say that my main focus the
entire career path i
only focused on innovations
and work for startups and with startups
that makes our life better in terms of
quality of life in terms of health
most of my career paths i focus in the
healthcare industry
are trying to develop drugs devices
diagnostics
uh for treating people for many years um
where combined technology and
and you know technology and science and
definitely also businesses
and and what defines me that i'm an
optimistic
you know i'm trying to look on the
bright side of the
of of the things that i'm facing with
and trying to you know
be creative and to believe that in the
end
we will find the best solution that we
should drive for it
right and so you study biotechnology
and then you get your master's from
northwestern university in the college
school of management
is it you know a plan that you know that
you're going to be going into you know
by technology in the tech space
and and work with startups and and help
them grow
um you know i don't know that
you know the the life that you know that
the way that i
was raised and you know my my father
uh he was uh also an independent and
a kind of an entrepreneur and that this
is part of the things that i you know
grow
up with um so i didn't know that i will
have my own startup you know it wasn't
so popular at that time that i was
young in a young age but definitely as i
realize you know
the as i realize what i like more and
what i like
less and the things that i want to do in
my life so i definitely
felt like you know that's my place i
want to to deal only with startups
and you know and once i got some success
uh so it even drives me more
to make additional impacts and to bring
new innovations to reality
um i think that in beginning when i was
young all the time i was very interested
in science
so during school in the army
in the academics i learned and studied
science so that's part of who i am
and through that those years of my
career path i also developed
additional tools like business tools
that i
was uh was lucky to you know to
collaborate and to work with great
companies and great startups with great
leaders and mentors
that provide me that aspect as well in
terms of business
and i closed it up when i went to the
executive
international executive mba at kellogg
to get a you know a formal recognition
and also to get additional ideas and
thoughts and
create a networking that will allows me
to grow faster
right and so with you know you i'm going
to skip quickly over
you know your time as chief operating
officer beyond there because i i really
want to hear
the story of savor eat and one of the
things that i gain a lot of inspiration
from
is you know the personal stories that
bring to
a to you know a need and and actually
that need then gets translated to
you know a company that actually you
know then goes to becomes
traded publicly so so tell me a little
bit about
about savory though is quite uh it's
quite unique you know i
you asked me about my my you know my
passion my history and
and did i thought about only having in
science part of what i'm doing
so most of my career path i focus at the
health care industry and i thought that
probably i you know i would continue
doing health care and continue to
develop drugs medicals and diagnostics
um and like six and a half years ago
i passed through a very severe episode a
medical episode
uh that you know
i needed to adopt in order to you know
to deal with that episode i need to
adopt a very restricted diet
i couldn't consume a high fat no sugar
no salt no salt wow a very last
caliber hydrate as much as possible
and trying to avoid you know uh
um high cholesterol things that can
cause you know like eggs and stuff like
this
and i was uh i was you know i really was
really frustrated because i couldn't
find
very good food to eat i didn't find
delicious
uh things that i got used to i couldn't
consume it
i was part it was part of my previous
preparation for the ipo for my previous
company i was work for
uh it was very stressful time for me and
i had
almost nothing to eat so in a way i i
just stopped eating i just eat the
minimum things that i needed
and drink a lot of water i lost a lot of
weight
and and what you know makes me very
unique i'm very passionate and energetic
personality
i was very weak frustrated um
and you know i realized that something
is it's much more bigger than you know
getting into
the area of developing drugs devices so
instead of focusing on that area and
trying to treat people by drugs and
devices
but rather think about it what's caused
us to be sick what's cause us to be ill
and
trying to get food in order to prevent
from us
to taking drugs and to to use medical
devices
so that was a tipping point when i
realized that i'm you know
i need to focus my energy in a different
direction
and i got interest in in the food
industry and you know in my imagination
was at that time
if i would have a machine that would
make me food according to what
i need according to what i want you know
and
not trying to get into the supermarket
and trying you know to make a puzzles in
order for something for me to consume
rather than just broccoli
uh that would be amazing you know and i
said okay probably someone invented it i
would go to google and i would try to
search for it
and i searched it in google i couldn't
find it it was just you know in
scientific uh articles or in movies
but not a reality and not a real
solution
so at that time at that time i was
really interested in you know getting
into the food industry and i realized
that
you know i'm talking about six and a
half years ago before
beyond meat and impossible and on the
entire food
ecosystem that we hear a lot about it
through the recent years and you know
through the recent
in the last two years i would say that
there is a there is a
huge progress in the foottech industry
you know prior to that it was you know
most of the innovations was managed by
you know the largest giant like universe
nestle
and the big names that they you know in
the end they innovated
they do they did some innovative
approach but they
mainly innovated their own product line
so we couldn't see a real technologies
coming into the
to the food industry it was very
conservative i would say
and as an entrepreneur i was i was
amazed i just thought about it that what
we can do
in addition to what we have today into
the food industry how much innovation
we can bring to that to that segment
and that's what the tipping point when i
realized that i'm moving to the food
industry
whatever it takes and i'm going to focus
on taking
beyond me and making making it
successful and pass through that
public uh offering and get the company
public and make
all the other investors and and
shareholders
and stakeholders happy with the results
of beyond there
and i'm moving to the to the food
industry
uh and i'm taking a break i did a break
of about a year
and searching for a solution that will
answer my need and i was
really lucky to find my partners uh
professor that you
from the agriculture university in
israel like five minutes from where i'm
living
it's it's it's completely uh it's
completely crazy
you know i went to the us i went to
europe i talked with
all the you know scientists here most of
the scientists in many universities and
i
you know five minutes from wherever yeah
it's five minutes
yeah it's crazy and you know we we
talked about it and then told them what
i'm
interesting in and whether they have
some solution technology is a
technological solution for that
and you know together you know they
develop something um
quite unique uh for a different
application for a different segment
and you know we took it we design it we
design it and we we
built together we incorporated together
savory in the end of 2018
and what we are doing at savory we're
developing a new way to recreate unique
experience the taste the flavor of meat
using proprietary plant-based
ingredients that was developed by the
agriculture university
and at savory together with a smart
robot
that allows us to create variety of
delicious products tasty meat with no
cholesterol without any phantom
functions that can be easily prepared
just with a push of a button
everything is being done automatically
within a few minutes
you get a product that manufactured and
grilled
and you can take it out of the machine
put it on a band
and enjoy the minute so this is what we
are doing
um and today as you mentioned we are
we are traded in a tel aviv stock
exchange we are a public company
uh and we are about to start a very uh
large pilot at bbb chain this is the
largest burger train in israel
uh within a few months and you know
the way that when we envision ourselves
you know in the beginning of 2022
we are planning to get into the u.s
market as well and trying to penetrating
so
a favorite product in that territory as
well and
quite exciting about that quite exciting
about the change that we're aiming to
bring to that market
and i feel like i'm very privileged to
be part of it and
to to leave a better world behind us in
a way a part of a legacy
uh into that into that market so um
this is who we are and we have
additional questions
and first of all you know obviously the
mission and the story and
and the execution and the the five
minutes from home and you know
that's all that is is incredible tell me
a little bit about
the decision to to go public on the
television stock exchange
um not a trivial decision and
not one that i come across often
i actually think you might be the first
or the second
person i have on the show that you know
is uh that
took this route um and two years or
three years
after inception so what what led to that
decision on your end um
you know as an entrepreneur um you know
one of the things that
we got used to do is all the time uh
you know be optimistic but at the same
time be pessimistic so all the time you
need to make
you need to have a list of opportunities
uh and options you have an option a you
have an option b option of c d
e and and so forth so one of the options
that we had on table because one of the
investors that invested us privately
before we would become an ipo
was one of the largest institutional
investors in israel and
and you know and they came to us and
they said okay there is an opportunity
now
in the tel aviv stock exchange that we
can take you public because it's
relatively very interesting story you
have a very huge progress
and it seems like it's going to fit uh
to feed that platform
okay he said okay i'm not saying no you
know i'm an entrepreneur so i'm keep my
mind open so let's
let's try to bring that option to the
table and trying to examine it
together with all the other options you
know getting into the vcs and getting
funds from vcs and the advantage and the
disadvantage of
each stage and you know the time frame
and and one of the
the you know one of the major resources
for a startup to be successful one of
its
major uh major uh uh process that they
need in order to be to become successful
are resources we need resources in terms
of time
in terms of money and you can buy time
so that process we have realized that we
take us faster
we can raise enough money for us up
until commercialization so this is
really this was the major part of the
decision so if you will go to a vc
you will probably will get we had a plan
to raise about uh
seven million dollars five to seven
million dollars uh you know with the
specific conditions as a vcs and while
you're going into the ipo
you you can raise much more money than
that and you know that can give you some
kind of um
of a you know a window to develop
your product without being of you know
taking care of
all the fundraising through that process
up until you
commercialize your product that that's
that's a huge advantage for a startup
you know with lack resources um so that
was
one of the reason why we made that
decision
and you know and and again i think that
we also got a very huge pr
from that area you know people are
getting to recognize us
and come to us and you have a potential
collaborations talking about the
collaborating with savory that is also
part of what is going on when you are
going public
and you know there are some
disadvantages like like you know like
life so
uh but uh yes it's quite unique
i would admit we were the first uh food
tech
company that was taking that path after
that after us
we saw additional companies are taking
the same path
um at least three additional companies
after us
came today to to an ipo yeah
and we are very happy with the to date
we're very happy with
with the decision you know what i'm
taking away from this and obviously you
know
to e every every situation requires a
different you know consideration and i'm
sure that we just scratched the surface
here with the various considerations
that came into play here
but i you know this idea that at any
given moment you have a variety of
possibilities and a variety of options
from option a to option e
and and being a confident and being able
to
to logically reason through those and
then understand what is the best one and
obviously having
that institutional investor that that
opens up that that opportunity that
maybe not a lot of even entrepreneurs
know
exists or knows the the the pros and
cons because
you know we're getting used to this to
our normalcy in the industry
where it's not a it's not in the
consciousness
you know advantage of a company but it
sounds like in your specific case
it made a lot a lot of sense and i have
to say that you know you're dealing in
the market that i'm personally extremely
passionate about i have no doubt
that companies like savory in this
industry are going to be you know
the forefront of of you know the world
and the way that we sustain ourselves
and and the fact that it comes out of a
personal experience
and then the this the working you know
with the agriculture university and
the the everything automatic automatic
and robot you're
combining a bunch of industries together
into a customer experience
that is well beyond just reinventing
meat it is
the it is the idea of how do we handle
the food from
from inception to production which i
think is is amazing
but rachel um now i'd like to ask you a
few questions
and not about safeword but about you are
you ready okay
good all right so we'll start off with
your favorite subject all the way back
in middle school or high school
your favorite subject favorite subject
i want to be honest with you sport
because i didn't like studying too much
when i was young um yeah so sport was my
my best class even though you went to
study biotechnology it's interesting
yeah i studied also you know biology and
chemistry at school but
uh that was really uh quite uh
exciting for me yeah take a break from
everything that i was studying
yeah who would be a role model of yours
or
or you know some figure of inspiration
in your life
okay so i i admire two people in my life
one of them is my father and the other
one is shimon peres
god bless his soul our founding father
and israeli founding fathers that you
know
um one of his you know
his recent job uh he wrote
his last uh his last uh his last book
called there is no room for a small
dream and
and this is uh if you will come to our
office
and you will get in you will see that
message
and that you know our founding fathers
uh
bring to our life you know in terms of
not to giving up your dreams and and
trying to to get your dreams into
reality
and i think that you know i have his
books here and
you know he's a legacy for me and you
know
is my one of my inspirations people i
love it and
who and what are three words that you
would use to describe yourself
uh i think that you know i would i would
try to think about what others would
think about me i think that i'm very
energetic personality
a lot of energy surrounding me i'm
trying to spread it all over
um so i'm really passionate about what
i'm doing you know when i have a mission
and i want to achieve it
no one can stop me it's like i will get
there no matter what
so i think that this is this is a part
of
who i am and i'm an optimistic you know
crazy optimistic and trying to look on
the bright side of life
and and you know i'm
i was you know gifted i'm i'm waking up
every morning smiling going back to
sleep smiling you know although we have
a lot of challenges and difficulties and
but this is part of who i
am and i'm trying to think you know very
positive because i believe that you know
once you
think positive you know the creation and
the things that you are doing probably
will go into the right direction so
that's what drives me
um and this is who i am rachel thank you
so so much
this was amazing best of luck with
savory i can't wait to go and taste it
for myself in the restaurant yeah so
come to baby change really soon
we we will start at october
so come visit us and taste it taste the
future take a bite
from our future i love it
stay safe stay healthy thank you for
coming here
[Music]